[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX CHAN: The digital content
space is changing rapidly.
Developers must
constantly search for ways
to monetize their product,
while continuously
enriching the user experience.
At Viki, subscriptions have
helped us create a sustainable
business.
We are almost tripling our
subscriber base every year,
and going to subscription
was easier than we thought.
My name is Alex Chan.
I'm the Senior VP of
Product and Engineering
at Viki, part of
the Rakuten family.
We are a global video
entertainment platform
with a heavy focus on Asian
content, both TV shows
and movies, powered by a
devoted community of fans.
We launched more
than six years ago
with a business model that
relied on ads for monetization.
We wanted a more
predictable revenue stream
and to offer better premium
experiences for our users.
So we launched subscriptions
through Google Play
three years ago.
It was really easy.
Just a few lines of code,
and the payment APIs
took care of the rest.
Our subscription
revenue has grown
over 200% in the past year.
We are blown away by
other positive outcomes
from the rollout.
MARILIAM SEMIDEY:
Android's [? growth ?]
in emerging markets
and open platforms
have really help us succeed.
Credit card use is slower
in these countries.
[? Committing ?] for some
payment from Google Play,
like gift cards and
carrier billing,
make payments
subscriptions easier
for users in these markets.
Our subscribers from
emerging markets
like Latin America
and the Middle East
have been growing at
more than 700% each year.
ALEX CHAN: Subscriptions
and Google Play billing
have helped us expand our paying
audience globally and opened up
a new stream of revenue
from emerging markets.
Now, we are making our
own shows while supporting
an active community of millions,
watching in over 200 languages.
Most important, our fans tell
us our product and content
has enriched their lives and
helped them learn new cultures.
This kind of impact
is what makes
our work truly fulfilling.